han pasado cinco meses desde que el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
dijera que estaba en contra de enviar
casas f-16 a Ucrania el viernes en la
Cumbre del g7 celebrada en Hiroshima se
retractó y dio oficialmente su
aprobación a las naciones que deseen
entrenar a pilotos ucranianos en los
preciados casas la decisión de Estados
Unidos supone un gran avance para que ha
solicitado infructuosamente a sus
aliados occidentales aviones de alta
tecnología para hacer frente a la
invasión rusa
acojo con beneplácito la decisión
histórica de los Estados Unidos y de
potos Para apoyar una coalición
internacional de aviones de combate esto
mejorará enormemente nuestro ejército en
el cielo cuento con discutir la
implementación práctica de esta decisión
en la Cumbre del g7 en Hiroshima
según un funcionario de la Casa Blanca
Estados Unidos está abierto a apoyar un
esfuerzo conjunto con sus aliados para
entrenar a los pilotos ucranianos en los
aviones así como a decidir cuándo
suministrar los f-16 cuántos se
proporcionarán y quién los proporcionará
Aunque algunas naciones occidentales
como Países Bajos Bélgica o Noruega
poseen varios f-16 de fabricación
estadounidense desde un punto de vista
legal Washington tiene que aprobar su
reexportación la decisión de Estados
Unidos también fue elogiada por los
aliados occidentales el país está
sustituyendo su flota de f-16 por casas
f-35 y ahora podrá avanzar en una
contribución colectiva para formar a
pilotos ucranianos en el pilotaje de los
f-16 Dinamarca hará todo lo posible para
que esta contribución sea prioritaria
sin embargo se tardan meses en entrenar
a un piloto sin hablar de los obstáculos
logísticos por solucionar